we're going to come down the level in
our live training environment we're
going to
put more controls in so that we have a
higher chance of actually cultivating
something okay
so rather than true gu where he does
whatever i do whatever he counters all
the way and i
address all his campaigns etc um
we're now going to add some control so
the first control
is you're not going to require the
immaterial connection because we're
going to start from the tactile
connection
okay um and then i'm going to focus in
on reconciling yin and yang
non-contestation of course work on your
ip and coke you
and so it's not very easy to figure out
how to do this kind of drill with these
control devices
such that i could actually do that full
live training environment of the other
day all right so
we start from the tactile thing and he
has a push you see
the way that he came in he had the push
so that's the thing i reconciled
there's there's his weight right there
you see
the way i did this this is where he
wants to fall so that's where i
play so we'll do the same thing it'll be
a little quicker
[Music]
and you'll see everything is still a
matter of deconstructing so i'm not
making him bend over i'm just going to
tilt him
take out his face
so uh tristan you guys will go
in anywhere i don't reconcile you
anywhere i can test anywhere i'm doing
something that will not
translate into yesterday's drill
where it's not partially sound this is
now
the drill's not working okay so here we
go
okay so you pick that ahead of time and
you can't pick ahead of time
okay so i'll show you show you what you
did the guy came in and you're already
how do i how do i know you ditch out
wash my hands watch my hands you see how
they moved already
can't work i need to use his energy
it's his energy he's pushing you see how
he pushes he's pushing down
so i used to push down you push then
get him done not here this is predicting
and i can't predict into you wasn't
try it again
okay so mechanically yes but you're
still choosing that technique
let his energy decide go
good a little behind you i'm not sure
that would have worked
so watch the uh other one
he's going to get behind me dizzy go
back
so i have a couple choices he gets
behind me up
you see i went up or
he got behind me only because i stayed
there
you see that it's only because i stayed
come back
so let's say i'm gonna predict i'm gonna
do that technique you'll see that it
doesn't look like he got behind me at
all
so it's only behind because you stopped
and because you wanted to do that other
technique
instead just keep working with the
energy pull
okay try it again
so i can't predict and i can't be
attached to the technique okay
[Music]
that was good you had to let go of the
first one right did you feel that
my mind got there knew it wasn't gonna
work can i let go right when you let go
that's the part we're training for
switch roles
so
get your arch up hey come in like this
no you off your head straight
you see you're predicting okay
so come in like that someone like that i
i'm just feeling it
feeling it it doesn't doesn't matter
what you're doing
doesn't matter what you're doing
so coming straight there you go i know
i'm not picking techniques
even perfect blend techniques even
perfect blending so i'm not picking
not picking that's not what we're doing
you push together that hands go on there
that's what i'm feeling that's telling
me what to do
okay
you had that little hiccup right you can
tell oh that's going to be
and then and then you yield right but
there was a
micro moment where you had to process
that
and in that micro moment that guy won't
be there in a full live environment
okay so it's a good it's a good step
because
this would be wrong but you went you did
go for it at first you see and then you
go okay that's not right
but that won't translate it's got to be
more that he's pushing he's pushing my
arm
you see because i don't have no
intention
with my arm there's no intention in my
arm
my arms are always just going to in
space
always just going to yank space okay
keep going
good better control the headband that's
not partial
so i'm here here i wanted your head
your head stand up stand up do you see
stand up do you see here's where you
control the head marshally okay
this is where your strikes okay
everything is here
stand up and so is kites and noggin
okay so keep your technique in the midst
of motion try it again
your mind got off and your weight
shifted to the heels
okay not marshall again
okay
okay so picking the technique is wrong
and unpicking the technique is
picking a technique so i'm picking a
technique is wrong too
okay come on out when priscilla you're
up
okay you are creepy it is going to be
tough
oh
don't keep your back if you're ready to
do that get back to side control
you're picking that ahead of time
if the hand is your shoulders
you're gonna need to tilt her okay you
can't bend people backwards
she decides the line not you you don't
decide the mind
is telling me where my foot goes okay
so i don't ever go here here and i go
this is where i go
that's not gonna work
there's your head and that's telling me
to go you got it
it's on this ham okay try it again
oh final i'm 15
[Music]
oh you're wasted okay yo
you're okay now you're okay
tilt
you watch your heel weight you can't go
to your heels okay
oh you're going to your heels because
he's pushing on you and he's only
pushing on you because you're pushing on
him
okay so he's going i want that technique
and
i don't want to push
so
come on
okay
you've got to get the first line lower
than the second line higher
i can't keep this high and then expect
to get that over
so boom heal low then this happens
higher than that
try it again okay there's still a
tactical promoting
again
okay let's go